This is Jocko podcast number 39 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
I heard of a high British officer who went over the battlefield just after the
action was over.
American boys were still lying dead in their foxholes.
Their rifle still grasped and firing position in their dead hands
and the veteran English soldier remarked time and again in a sort of hushed
eulogy spoken only to himself.
Okay.
Brave man.
Brave men.
Yeah,
and that is the name of the book we're going to delve into now.
brave men can.
A few episodes ago we talked with Kiron Dardy
war photographer and when we talk with him,
we talked about war correspondents as well and I wanted to
get
a war correspondent here and in this case,
the one that we're going to be talking to is possibly the most famous war
correspondent ever guy by the name of Ernie pile
and we will join him now,
Paul,
a warship
steaming towards an inevitable invasion.
The front line soldier I knew lived for months like an animal and it was a
veteran in the cruel,
fierce squirreled of death.
Everything was abnormal and unstable in his life.
He was filthy dirty eight if and when a slept on hard ground without cover.
His clothes were greasy and he lived in a constant haze of dust pastored by
flies and heat moving,
constantly deprived of all things that met once meant stability,
things such as walls,
chairs,
floors,
windows,
faucets,
shelves,
Coca Cola.
And the little matter of knowing that he would go to bed at night in the same
place he had left in the morning,
the front line soldier has to harden his inside as well as his outside or he
would crack under the strain.
Okay.
Some thoughts from Ernie pile out on a ship getting ready for this invasion,
talking about what the soldiers were like and he'd been in Africa and now he's
out there with sailors and he has something to say about the sailors as well.
Of course when sailors die,
death for them is just as horrible and sometimes they die in greater masses than
soldiers,
but until the enemy comes over the horizon,
a sailor doesn't have to fight a front line soldier has to fight everything all
the time.
It makes a difference in a man's character.
And Ernie pile goes on to talk about
what he thinks of the front line soldier.
Everyone by now knows how I feel about the infantry.
I'm a rabid one man movement bent on tracking down and stamping out everybody
else in the world who doesn't fully appreciate the common front line soldier.
And if I haven't made myself perfectly clear
in everything I say in everything I do,
that's the same exact feeling that I have about the infantry,
respect and admiration.
And now he's talking about what it was like,
what are the,
what's going through their minds as they're going to partake in this,
our invasion it and you gotta remember he's going on an invasion to wait when
when he,
when these things are happening.
This is a war correspondent.
This isn't somebody that's reporting from some safe position and you,
and you're going to see plenty of that here.
He's going in so he can relate to what the troopers are going through mentally.
And this is a very really
accurate
description.
And back to the book.
I don't believe one of us was afraid of the physical part of dying.
That isn't the way it is.
The emotion is rather one of almost desperate reluctance to give up the future.
Okay.
They're not afraid of the physical stuff.
It's the reluctance to give up the future.
I suppose.
That's splitting hairs and that it really all comes under the heading of fear.
Yet somehow there is a difference.
These gravely yearned for futures of men.
Going into battle includes so many things,
things such as seeing the old lady again of going to college,
of staying in the navy for a career of holding on need just once your own kid
whom you've never seen.
Okay.
Of again,
becoming champions,
salesman of your territory or driving a coal truck around streets of Kansas City
once more and yes,
even just sitting in the sun once more on the south side of a house in New
Mexico.
Yeah.
When we huddled around together on the dark decks,
it was these little hopes and ambitions that made up the sum total of our worry
at leaving rather than any visualization of physical agony to come.
Very,
very accurate.
Now
and I,
I,
I gotta say that with this book,
this is a fairly fairly thick book.
What do we got?
Almost 500 pages and I have to burn through big chunks of it
to get to some of the stuff that I wanted to cover.
But there's a lot of very important detail in here.
And one of the things that Ernie Pyle was known for was capturing what it was
like,
not for the big general,
not for the big strip strategist,
but what it was like to live every day as an,
as a grunt.
So the invasion takes place and I think this was the,
uh,
they,
they went into Italy and Ernie actually spent that invasion on the ship,
the initial part of the invasion.
And then he goes ashore.
And for whatever reason he gets sick.
It's like sick ill,
it doesn't get wounded but just gets ill and he ends up in a field hospital.
Okay.
And we've had several,
several books take us into field hospitals and we know that they are a horrible,
horrible place.
But there is,
yeah,
some pretty glorious things that come out of those two.
And I'll go to the book here.
It was flabbergasting to me to lie there and here wounded soldiers costs and
begged to be sent right back to the fight.
Of course not all of them did that.
It depended on the severity of their wounds and on their individual
personalities just as it wouldn't peace time,
but at least a third of the less severely wounded men asked if they couldn't
return to duty immediately.
Yeah.
So all those fears that we just talked about.
And then you go into battle and you get wounded and the first thing you do when
you get back to the aid station and say,
send me back to the front.
Yeah.
He goes into a specific case here.
One big blonde infantry men had slight flesh wounds in the face and the back of
his neck.
He had a patch on his upper lip which prevented him from moving it and made him
talk in a grave straight faced manner.
That was comical.
I've never seen anybody so mad in my life.
You went from one doctor to another trying to get somebody assigned his card,
returning him to duty.
The doctors explained patiently that if he returned to the front,
his wounds become infected and he would be a burden to his company instead of a
help.
They tried to entice him by telling him there would be nurses back in the
hospital,
but it is peaceful Oklahoma drawl.
He retorted to hell with the nurses.
I want to get back to fighting.
Dying men were brought into our 10 men whose death rattle,
silence the conversation and made us all thoughtful.
When a man was almost gone,
the surgeons would put a piece of gauze over his face.
He could breathe through it,
but we couldn't see his face.
Well twice within five minutes,
chaplains came running.
One of those occasions haunted me for hours.
The wounded man was still semi-conscious.
The chaplain knelt down beside him and to ward boys squatted nearby.
The chaplain said,
John,
I'm going to say a prayer for you.
Somehow this stark announcement hit me like a hammer.
It didn't say,
I'm going to pray for you to get well.
He just said he was going to say a prayer and it was obvious to me that he meant
a final prayer.
He voiced the prayer and the weak gasping man tried vainly to repeat the words
after him.
When he had finished the chaplain added,
John,
you're doing fine.
You're doing fine.
Then he rose and dashed off on some other call and the ward boys,
when about their duties,
the dying man was left utterly alone.
Just lying there on his litter,
on the ground,
lying in an aisle because the tent was full.
Okay.
Of course it couldn't be otherwise,
but the aloneness of that man as he went through the last few minutes of his
life was what tormented me.
Okay.
I felt like going over and at least holding his hand while he died.
Yeah,
but it would have been out of order and I didn't do it.
I wish now I had,
yeah.
In addition to talking about the infantry,
he also talks about the engineers and for those of you that don't know,
engineers are basically military construction people that build things.
They also do other like getting rid of minds and doing mine clearance.
They do that often as well,
and
we'll go back to the book.
During the latter days of the Sicilian campaign,
I spent all my time with combat engineers,
have two different divisions.
The engineer's were in it up to their ears,
scores of times during the Sicilian fighting.
I heard everybody from generals to privates remark that this is certainly an
engineer's war and indeed it was every foot of our advance upon the gradually
withdrawing enemy was measured by the speed with which our engineers could open
the highways,
clear the mines,
and bypass the blown bridges
on this.
This was the same thing
that
we,
we hadn't Ramadi the,
the engineers were just absolutely.
First of all,
they were incredibly professional and their job was incredibly dangerous.
They were clearing mines.
They were doing these building,
these combat outposts and middle of the city,
are they armed the engineers,
like in your case?
Yeah,
they are.
But you know,
picture a guy that has to go in and move sand bags at the top of a building.
He's,
he's carrying a 60 pound sandbag.
He's got all of his gear on and,
and it's a semi protected area.
Not fully protected,
but so a lot of times,
hey,
they're there.
They might have a pistol on him,
but they're working their construction work.
They're working construction.
Yup.
You don't.
Now that doesn't mean that they're not also picking up security when they have
to,
but man,
it's a,
it's a grueling,
grueling job and in so incredibly dangerous and
okay.
The book also talks about other pieces.
You know,
again,
we talked about infantry,
but there's other pieces.
There's engineers who are doing all this building.
There's artillery,
which is,
you know,
dropping bombs on the enemy.
And actually it was another,
surprisingly,
there was art we utilized,
they utilized artillery fairly significantly in Ramadi.
Yeah.
It's,
when you think about that,
like the engineers in a war zone,
right.
It's not like compared to like an MMA fight,
The cut man where he's like facilitating all these scenes,
giving water,
whatever.
But that'd be tweeting rounds.
He's not part of the fight.
The engineer guys,
the engineers,
they're going to get hit.
But here's the thing,
they're not there specifically to fight.
Yeah,
they're there to do some other stuff.
So it's like,
man,
they can get blindsided,
like all that stuff.
It's incredibly,
and,
and yet,
you know,
you think,
oh,
it's an engineer's.
They're construction guys.
You maybe people don't,
don't see them in the light of being legit combat warriors.
And I'm here to tell you 100% without any shred of doubt.
Those guys are hardcore combat warriors that have an incredibly tough job.
And obviously the American engineers had been just outstanding World War II.
I mean,
and when I saw them in Ramadi,
they were a sight to behold without question.
And same thing,
like I said,
I was talking about the artillery.
They used artillery unit in Ramadi,
who as well,
which was,
it was pretty cool for me.
Right.
Cause you know,
I always grew up watching World War II movies and,
and you know,
there I was in Ramadi,
man,
we had tanks out there in the streets,
smashing through,
smashing through buildings and firing their main gun rounds.
And then we had engineers out there rebuilding bridges and building combat
outposts.
And then we had artillery that was firing counter battery out in at the enemy
that was shooting mortars at us.
And at nighttime sometimes we'd fire illumination rounds,
just like a big assault in a World War II.
So it was very well I was,
I feel very lucky to have been able to experience that,
that almost,
you know,
World War II type feeling.
Now again,
I'm not comparing anything that I did do a veteran from world war two by any
stretch of the imagination,
but it was cool to get a little taste,
just a little this,
a little taste of it,
just a little taste of it and understand.
I mean,
I can't,
you know,
we were,
the,
the imagine fighting against other troops that were as well trained as you are,
which is what you're doing in Germany when you're free,
when you're invading France,
you're going against,
I mean,
the insurgence there,
they're all hard fight.
They're an enemy that I respect their capabilities,
but they're not as well trained or as well organized or as well led as let's say
the German army in World War II.
Right.
So it's a
tough enemy.
And so as he continues through the book,
and as I said,
this is a big thick book and I had to really be selective about what to call
out.
And he talks about the various phases of the war.
He talks a pretty big chunk about the air war,
but really it's all leading towards
one thing.
It's all leading towards one event.
It's all leading towards one invasion.
And that's d day.
Hmm.
And he spends time in England,
you know,
they're doing the preparation and they're having,
they're doing what the Americans did in England when they were getting ready.
And then finally they get the word that the mission is going to commence
and we'll go to the book.
We felt our chances were not very good and we were not happy about it.
Men like dawn Whitehead and Clark Lee who had been through the mill so long and
so boldly began to get nerves.
Frankly,
I was the worst of the lot and continued to be.
I began having terrible of depression and often would dream hideous dreams all
the time.
Fear,
lay Blackley deep upon our consciousness.
It board down on our hearts like an all consuming weight.
People would talk to us and we wouldn't want to hear what they were saying of
those.
Again,
those are the correspondence.
Those were the war correspondence.
That's the guy who he's talking about when they,
when they bring them together,
they're talking like a squad or a platoon of war correspondents and they are
scared to death.
The army said they were trying to give us 24 hours notice of departure.
Actually,
the call came at nine o'clock one morning and we were ordered to be in a certain
place with full field kit at 10:30 AM we threw our stuff stuff together.
Probably a smart way to do it,
you know,
hey,
we'll give you 24 hours advanced notice,
don't worry.
You know,
we'll let you know,
hey,
reporting an hour cause cause,
and he tells he's going to talk about this.
The waiting isn't,
is not good.
That is,
that is the stress part.
And it's the same thing with everything.
Anything that you actually,
you'll look at Jujitsu tournament when you're waiting to compete.
That's the worst part.
Once you won't,
you go,
okay,
your mind is free and you're just doing what you do even during a workout.
Yeah.
If you've got a hard workout that you're going to do,
you're dreading it.
And I do this.
I'll be like for like if I have squats,
I'm sitting there,
I'll make all kinds of what maybe I need to stretch a little bit more.
You know what,
let me just grab a little bit more water and uh,
and then let me check the lineup of the music that's going to play and just make
sure that that's good to go.
And hold on was this,
is this bumper plate look straight.
I'm going to straighten that out.
So you just sit there and having hall and then finally you walk over,
you press your press,
your start in your stock stopwatch and then there's no stopping.
You just go and it half an hour later the deed is done,
you know,
but the waiting.
Yup.
Yeah.
If it's going down,
let's get it over with kind of thing.
You know what this is that Shakespeare quote that I read one time when here that
that moment in between taking the action and when you think of the action and
when you take the action,
that moment is an eternity best.
So you got to close the distance on that thing,
which is exactly what they did.
Oh,
we'll give you 24 hours.
Nowhere in closed the distance.
You've got an hour and a half here with your gear ready to get it on
back to the book.
Bill Stoneman,
another correspondent who had been wounded once,
never showed the slightest concern whether he felt any concern or not.
I could not tell bill had a humorous,
sardonic manner.
While we were waiting for the departure into the unknown,
he took out a pencil and a notebook.
Okay.
As though starting to interview me,
tell me,
Mr Pile,
how does it feel to be an assault correspondent?
Being a man of few words,
I said,
it feels awful.
We had hardly got a board when the lines were cast off and we pulled out that
evening.
The colonel commanding the troops on our ship gave me the whole invasion plan in
detail.
The secret,
the whole world had waited years to here.
Once a man had heard it,
it became permanently part of it.
He became permanently part of it.
Then he was committed.
It was too late to back out,
even if his heart failed him.
I asked a good many questions.
I realized my voice was shaking when I spoke,
but I couldn't help it.
Yes,
it will be tough to colonel admitted,
admitted our own part would be precarious.
He hoped to go in with his few cash pleased as possible,
but there would be casualties
from a vague anticipatory dread.
The invasion now turned into a horrible reality for me in a matter of hours.
The holocaust of our own planning would swirl over us.
No Man could guarantee his own fate.
It was almost too much for me,
a feeling of utter desperation obsessed me throughout the night.
It was nearly 4:00 AM before I got to sleep and then it was a sleep harassed and
torn by an awful knowledge.
Okay.
My devastating sense of fear and depression disappeared when we approached the
beach head.
There was the old familiar crack and ruler of big guns all around us and the
shore was a great brown haze of smoke and dust and we knew that the bombers
would be over us that night.
Yet all the haunting premonition,
the soul consuming dread was gone.
The war was presented to me again and I believe that was true of everyone,
a board,
even those who had never been in combat before.
So again,
once this gig kicks off,
all that horror is gone and now it's time to get the job done.
So when you're out there in the world and you're feeling that dread and you're
feeling that hesitation,
just step,
go,
Yup.
It's not helping you to sit around and be nervous.
It's not helping you to to see if he needed a little sip of water before we
start doing what you're doing.
Yeah.
There's bad news to deliver on your business.
There's no sense in doing another pace lap outside though the room where people
are waiting to hear from you,
get in and get it going.
Now he,
he does a great job here telling about how hard this actually was.
Cause you know,
we'd go,
Oh d day.
Yeah,
we,
oh yeah,
it was a tough fight.
Here's some detail on that.
I want to tell you what the opening of the second front in that one sector
entailed so that you can know and appreciate and forever be humbly grateful to
those both dead and alive.
Who did it for you.
Yeah.
Ashore facing us wore more enemy troops than we had in our assault waves.
The advantages,
we're all,
there's the disadvantages.
All ours,
the Germans were dug into positions they had been working on for months,
although they were not entirely complete.
A 100 foot bluff,
a couple of hundred yards back from the beach,
had had great concrete gun emplacements built right into the hilltop.
These open to the sides instead of the front,
thus making it hard for naval fire from the seed to reach them.
They could shoot parallel to the shore and cover every foot of it from miles
with artillery.
Fire a hundred foot cliff.
By the way,
just don't,
let's not even worry about the enemy.
A hundred foot cliff after you come out of the water.
That's what you're facing.
Then you put in pill boxes and you put Germans in those pillboxes by the way.
More Germans than there are Americans.
Yeah,
it's a nightmare.
Back to the book.
Then they had hidden machine gun nest on the forward slopes with crossfire
taking in every inch of the beach.
These nests were connected by networks of trenches so that the German gunners
could move about without exposing themselves throughout the length of the beach
running zig zag a couple of hundred yards back from the shoreline.
What is an immense V's shape ditch 15 feet deep.
Nothing could cross it,
not even men on foot until it feel until fills had been made and in other places
at the forum of the beach where the ground was flatter,
they had concrete walls.
These were blasted by our naval gunfire or buy explosives by hand.
After we got a shore,
our only exits from the beach where several swales or valleys,
each one about a hundred yards wide,
the Germans made the most of those funnel light traps sewing them with buried
minds.
They also contained barbed wire entanglements with mines attached hidden ditches
and machine guns firing from the slopes.
This is just,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable the amount of defenses that were in placed and the fact that
we pushed through it,
and I humbly use the term we
all this was done on the shore,
but our men had to go through a maze nearly as deadly before the even goddess
shore.
Underwater obstacles were terrific under the water.
The Germans had whole fields of evil devices to catch our boats.
Several days after landing.
We had cleared only channels through them and still could not approach to the
whole length of the beach with our ships.
Even then,
some ship or boat would hit one of those minds and be knocked out of commission.
The Germans had masses of great six prongs.
Spiders made of railroad iron and standing shoulder high just beneath the
surface of the water for our landing craft to run into.
Okay.
They had huge logs buried in the sand pointing upward and outward.
Their tops just below the water attached to the logs were mines.
In addition to these obstacles,
they had floating minds off shore landmines buried in the sand of the beach and
more mines checkerboard in checkerboard rose in the tall grass.
Beyond the sand.
The and the enemy had four men on shore for every three men we had approaching
the shore
and yet we got on.
Yeah.
Going against a defended position is so very difficult.
The odds.
Well,
in in doctrinally in urban warfare,
you're supposed to have 10 men for every one defender,
10 men for every one defender.
And here we weren't out outmanned
against a heavily defended before to find position.
So how do you do it?
Well,
back to the book,
as one officer said,
the only way to take a beach is to face it and keep going.
It is costly at first,
but that is the only way.
If the men are pinned down on the beach,
dug in and out of action,
they made as well,
not be there at all.
They hold up the waves behind them and nothing is being gained.
Yeah.
So art of war,
Sun Tzu attack.
What?
Guess what you get?
There's only one way to do this.
You gotta do it.
Okay.
Now he talks about
as the carnage after the,
after the initial beachhead had been taken,
he talks about some of the carnage that remains there
in this shoreline museum of carnage.
There were abandoned rolls of barbed wire and smashed boulder dozers and big
stacks of thrown away lifebelts and piles of shells still waiting to be moved
in.
The water floated empty life rafts and soldiers packs and and boxes and
mysterious oranges on the beach lay snored,
rolls of telephone wire and big rolls of steel matting and stacks of broken
rusting rifles.
Yeah,
but there was another and more human litter.
It extended in a thin little line,
just like a high watermark for miles along the beach.
This was the strewn personal gear gear that would never be needed again by those
who fought and died to give us our entrance into Europe.
Yeah,
they're in a jumbled role for mile one mile.
We're soldiers packs.
There were socks and shoe Polish,
sewing kits,
diaries,
bibles,
hands,
Gurney,
hand grenades.
There were the latest letters from home with the address on each one neatly
razor it out.
One of the security precautious enforced before the boys embarked,
there were toothbrushes and razors and snapshots of families back home staring
up at you from the sand.
There were pocketbooks,
metal mirrors,
extra trousers and bloody abandoned shoes.
There were broken handled shovels and portable radio smashed almost beyond
recognition and mine detectors twisted and ruined.
There were torn pistol belts and canvas water buckets,
first aid kits and jumbled heaps of life belts.
I picked up a pocket Bible with a soldier's name in it and put it in my jacket.
I carried it half a mile or so and then put it back down on the beach.
I don't know why I picked it up or why put it down again.
Soldiers carry strange things with them ashore in every invasion.
There's at least one soldier hitting the beach at eight h hour with a Banjo
slung over his shoulder.
The most ironic piece of equipment marking our beach,
the first this beach,
first of despair.
Then a victory was a tennis racket that some soldier had brought along the lay
lonesome Lee on the sand clamped and it's press,
not a string broken.
Two of the most dominant items on the beach.
Refuse in the beach.
Refuse were cigarettes and writing paper.
Each soldier was issued a carton of cigarettes just before he started that day,
those cartons by the thousand water soaked and spilled out.
Mark the line of our first savage blow.
Yeah,
writing paper and air mail envelopes came second.
The boys and tended to do a lot of writing in France.
Imagine the letters now forever incapable of being written that might have
filled those blank abandoned pages.
Now
talking a little bit about the German prisoners as they start to roll up German
prisoners.
Some of the German officers,
we're pleased at being captured,
but the died in the WWE,
but the dyed in the wool Nazi was not.
They brought in a young one who is furious.
He considered it thoroughly unethical for us to fight so hard.
That's right.
Did you heard what I said?
He thought it was unethical how hard the Americans fought.
The Americans had attacked all night and the Germans don't like a night attacks
were coming to get you,
and this special fellow was brought in.
When the special fellow was brought in,
he protested in rage.
You Americans,
the way you fight that is,
this is not war.
This is madness.
The German was so outraged.
She never even got the irony of his own remarks.
That madness though it were.
It worked.
Another high ranking officer was brought in and the first thing he asked was the
whereabouts of his personal orderly when told that is orderly was deader than a
mackerel.
He flew off the handle and accused us of depriving him of his personal comfort.
Who's going to dig my foxhole for me?
He demanded a little German aristocracy going on in the ranks,
but what a,
what a testament.
You always just kind of talking about how tough the Germans were,
which they certainly were,
but here's the German saying,
good.
Lowered.
It's unethical that you fight this hard.
That's right.
Red.
The Germans thought they were rolling light,
you know,
hey,
let's roll later.
And the Americans were like,
Nah,
we're going ADCC style or you don't know it's on the world championships.
Yeah.
Literally.
Yeah,
we're really happy jokes.
I always uh,
you know,
American,
the American fighting spirit is a powerful,
powerful force and sometimes people don't recognize that because you know what,
we're living here pretty good.
And even back then,
now we're coming out of the depression.
So you did have some hard back in America,
but you can trace that pre depression Americans fight hard.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about it.
And I can,
I've personally personally witnessed the spirit of the American soldier and it
is a damn impressive thing
going to get into some,
well the name of the chapter here is street fighting.
One of,
one of the favorite generals among war correspondence was major general Manton s
Eddie Commander of the ninth division.
We liked him because he was absolutely honest with us because he was sort of an
old shoe and easy to talk with him because we thought he was a mighty good
general,
General Ed.
He looked more like a school teacher,
then a soldier.
He was a big tall man.
But he wore glasses in his eyes,
had a sort of squint being a widow Midwesterner.
He talked like one,
he still claims Chicago is home,
although he'd been an army officer for 28 years.
He was
wounded in the last war.
He was not Glib,
but he talked well and laughed easily.
In spite of being a professional soldier,
he despised war and like in any ordinary soul was appalled by the waist and
tragedy of it.
He wanted to win and get home just as badly as anybody else.
General Eddie especially like to show up in places where it's soldiers wouldn't
expect to see him.
Little leadership lessons right now from General Eddie,
nothing wrong with smiling,
talking with the boys,
no one what's going on and then boom,
show up in places where his soldiers wouldn't expect to see him.
He knew it helped the soldiers spirits to see their commanding general right up
there at the front where it was hot.
So we walked around the front with his long stride,
never ducking or appearing to be concerned at all.
One day I rode around with him on one of his tours.
We stopped at a command post and we're sitting on the grass under a tree looking
at maps with a group of officers around us.
Our own military was near banging nearby,
but nothing was coming our way.
Then like a flash of lightening there came Michelle just over our heads so low.
It went right through the tree tops.
It seemed,
it didn't whine.
It wished it squished.
Everybody including full colonels flopped over and begin grabbing grass.
The shell exploded in the next orchard.
General Ed,
he didn't move.
He just said that was one of our shells.
Okay.
The general also like to get up at four o'clock in the morning once in a while,
to go poking around into the message.
Genders in mess halls,
given the boys a start.
Yeah.
It sounds like he was a little bit an early riser.
It's trying to be up before the enemy is definitely up before the enemy.
Well,
apparently,
you know the Germans,
they were saying,
hey,
your nighttime.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
During the sheer board peninsula campaign.
I spent nine days with the Ninth Infantry Division,
the division that cut the peninsula and one of the three that overwhelmed the
great port of share Moose.
The ninth is one of our best divisions.
It landed in Africa and fall through Tunisia and Sicily.
Then it went to England in the fall of 1943 and trained all winter for the
invasion of France was one of the American divisions in the invasion that had
previous battle experience.
The ninth did something in that campaign that we hadn't always done in the past.
It kept tenaciously on the enemy's neck.
When the Germans grew,
withdraw little,
the ninth was right on top of them.
It never gave them a chance to reassemble or get their balance.
The ninth moves so fast.
It got to be funny.
I was based at the division command post and we struck our tents and move
forward six times in seven days that work the daylights out of the boys who took
down and put up the tents.
I overheard one of the boys saying,
I'd rather be with Ringling brothers,
but that's a little strategic importance there.
The ninth was just,
Oh,
oh,
we're,
we're going to get you and we're going to come after you and we're not going to
stop.
You're not going to get a chance to recover and not get a chance to rest.
Sometimes you've got to go in that mode no matter what what you're doing in
life.
Sometimes you got to go in that mode.
You don't back off and I'll tell you what you want to arrest.
People want to rest,
but sometimes you can't.
Sometimes you need to keep the pressure on
kind of like you and Twitter.
Yes.
Had to keep some pressure on
one day I went along quite accidentally.
I assure you with an infantry company that had been assigned to clean out a
pocket in the suburbs of share boomers since the episode was typically of the
way an infantry advanced into the city,
held by a by an enemy.
I would like to try and give you a picture of it so he's going to try and like
explain what that was like.
The soldiers around us had two weeks growth of beard and before he talks about
the assault,
he kind of gives you a little update on this other than the front line in
between troops.
The soldiers around us had two weeks growth of beard.
Their uniforms were worn,
worn,
slick and very dirty.
The uncomfortable gas impregnated close.
They'd come assurance con come ashore in.
The boys were tired.
They had been fighting and moving constantly forward on foot for nearly three
weeks without rest,
sleeping on the ground wet most of the time.
Always tents,
eating cold rations,
seeing their friends die.
One of them came up to me and said,
almost belligerently,
why don't you tell the folks back home what this is like.
All they hear about his victories and a lot of the glory stuff,
they don't know that for every hundred yards we advance,
somebody gets killed.
Why don't you tell them how tough this life is?
I told him that I tried to do that all the time.
This fellow was pretty fed up with it all.
He said he didn't see why his outfit wasn't sent home.
They had done all the fighting.
That wasn't true at all for their one other divisions that had fought more and
taking heavier casualties.
Exhaustion will make a man feel like that a few days.
Rest usually has him smiling again.
You know,
and we've heard this time and time again,
sometimes you start get that mental fatigue.
You've got to take a little breather.
So yeah,
like the ninth sometimes you've got to keep the pressure on,
but if you start to break people,
maybe it's time,
especially in an individual.
And you know,
Dick winters did this for band of brothers,
Dick Winters,
beyond,
beyond the band of brothers.
He talked about,
Hey,
I've got this guy that's a little losing the bubble and the pulling back,
hey,
you got some admin stuff to do in the rear.
Want to go ahead and take care of that.
Boom,
done.
Let this guy,
he'll up.
What this guy needs?
He needs a break.
You need to rest.
And here we get the little briefing,
a little briefing from the lieutenant,
who's going to tell them how they're going to push through this little and clear
out this little pocket of enemy resistance.
This is how we'll do it.
The lieutenant said a rifle platoon goes first.
Right behind them.
We'll go a part of the heavy weapons platoon with machine guns to cover the
first platoon.
Then comes another rifle platoon,
then a small section with mortars in case they run into something pretty heavy.
Then another rifle platoon and bringing up the rear the rest of the heavy
weapons outfit to protect us from behind.
We don't know what we'll run into and I don't want to stick right out in front,
so why don't you come along with me.
So he's talking to Ernie Pyle at that point saying,
listen,
I don't know what's gonna be up front.
You stick with me.
We'll go in the middle of the company.
I said,
okay,
by this time I wasn't scared.
You seldom are.
Once you're into something,
anticipation is the worst.
Fortunately,
this little foray came up so suddenly there wasn't time for much anticipation.
The waiting,
so they take,
they start taking a little fire and finally the shells stop and here we go.
The shell stopped and finally the order to start was given.
As we left the protection of the high wall,
we had to cross a little covert right out in the open and then make a turn in
the road.
The men went forward one at a time.
They crouched and ran eight blight apelike across this dangerous space.
Then beyond the culvert,
they filtered to either side of the road,
stopping and squatting down every now and then to wait a few moments.
The lieutenant kept yelling at them as they started spread it out.
Now do you want to draw fire at yourselves?
Don't bunch up like that.
Keep five yards apart,
spread it out.
Dammit.
There's an almost irresistible pull to get close to somebody when you're in
danger.
In spite of themselves.
The men would run up close to the fellow ahead of them for company.
But obviously if you're close to your,
you're close to people and one,
well first of all in one bullet can kill two people,
but you get hit with a bomb.
You get hit with a grenade,
you're going to kill multiple people.
So you want to disperse,
you want to keep your dispersion,
it will spread out.
But there's this little thing that people want to just get close to other
people.
Yeah.
And everybody knows it's wrong.
And actually if you remember in the,
uh,
in the beloved captain,
that's what he was costing St guys spread out in the trench.
Don't,
Hey,
don't bunch up.
And the,
and,
and the author was saying,
we all just wanted to huddle together.
You want to get close together.
You're in fear.
So you want to huddle and it's the wrong move.
Yeah.
Now we get into description of the men as they're making this cross.
The men didn't talk amongst themselves,
they just went,
they weren't heroic figures as they moved forward.
One at a time,
few seconds apart.
You think of attackers as being savage and bold.
These men were hesitant and cautious.
They were really the hunters,
but they looked like the hunted.
There was a confused excitement into grim anxiety in their faces.
They seemed terribly pathetic to me.
They weren't warriors.
They were American boys who by mere chance of fate had wound up with guns in
their hands,
sneaking up death,
Wade and street in a strange and shattered city in a far away country and a
driving rain.
They were afraid,
but it was beyond their power to quit.
They had no choice.
They were good boys.
I talked with them all afternoon as we sneak slowly in word along the mysterious
and rubbled street.
And I know they were good boys and even though they weren't warriors born to
kill,
they won their battles.
That's the point.
Regular guys,
World War,
two regular guys in,
in it's,
it's not depicted.
They'll throw a character like that and to a movie you don't,
oh he's,
you know,
just,
it looks like a regular guy.
But most of the guys don't.
The Vanilla regular guys,
they look like bad ass war hero guys.
And this is such a,
you don't hear this description where he's literally saying,
um,
they weren't warriors.
They seemed terribly pathetic.
And so you picture these guys that got this scared,
strange look on their face and guess what?
They do their job.
Yeah.
And they do it well yet strange.
It's almost like you can look at them in both ways because on the one hand
they're just regular guys.
But when you see him in action kind of thing,
you're like all Dang,
they're getting out of their warriors.
You know it's true.
I mean he clearly the warriors that,
like he said,
they,
when their battles and even what they're doing right now,
it takes massive courage.
You're getting ready to step across the street where you know there's a machine
gun fire could open up and take your life or take your legs or you know,
wound you
that that takes some will that takes some disciplined.
Yeah.
I mean,
how can you not just cower in the first corner?
You see really,
you know,
when you compare it to everyday life,
man,
I mean I don't,
I hate to,
but I can't help but compare it to saving private Ryan that that might be right.
And there's a part where they indicate that everyone's been trying to guess
the job of the Oh yeah,
Miller,
whatever.
They're trying to guess it right.
And so that was like an exposure of like yeah,
this is of the humanity and the yeah.
You know,
back then and
then he's like,
yeah,
I'm a school teacher and all this stuff,
all this like normal stuff.
And then meanwhile as the movie kind of progress,
you see him in action.
It's like Dang for a school teacher,
these guys are,
you know,
they're really getting the job.
Man.
We were,
when I first got Ramadi,
we were there with the,
uh,
the two to eight,
which is a,
which is a reserve unit from Pennsylvania,
iron soldiers and led by a guy at the time was named Colonel Grand Ski.
He's now a general,
but those guys were school teachers.
They were,
I mean cause they were reservists.
So there was guys who were school teachers,
there was guys there that were plumbers,
there was guys that are there,
cable installers that were guys there that were mechanics.
There was guys there that were lawyers.
They're just every job.
And yet these guys were there fighting straight up and getting after it by the
way to battle hardened.
And really they were,
they were so impressive and we are so humbled by these guys.
These reservists,
they were bad ass.
Nothing.
But again,
nothing but respect and admiration for them on the battlefield.
Yeah man.
And the exactly where if let's say you didn't know their job outside of the,
you know the battle and you see them,
you're like Dang,
these guys are straight up.
This is their thing.
This is what their,
their primary career is.
You know,
that's what it seems like.
And I'll tell you,
I just was out in Mississippi and I was with a bunch of guys that were
reservists and Mississippi and one of the guys I was talking to,
multiple guys that was talking to,
they had multiple deployments to Iraq and,
and these are 12 month deployment.
14 month deployments.
These guys were awesome,
awesome guys,
awesome professionals who had taken the fight to the enemy.
So it's amazing that that America has these,
these reservists that live their lives.
And then,
oh by the way,
you're going to go on deployment to Iraq for 14 months right now and get after
it.
Then you can come back and go into your normal job again following it back in
and go and just be straight up affective.
Yup.
Not like they're,
they're like timid,
you know,
cause I'm,
Hey,
I'm just here for 14 months,
back home.
I'm,
you know,
I work at office,
whatever.
They're like,
nope,
watch me,
watch me get it much.
We get it on.
So
we get to a point now that you know,
that street fight continues,
they take down,
they clear that pocket,
there's more combat description,
but now they're getting ready to push out of Normandy beach outlay.
They've,
so they've taken the beach,
they've secured it,
they've taken some hedge rows,
they've got it locked in.
It's been,
it's been,
you know,
some time,
but now they're getting ready to start making the push,
making the push out of there.
And so that's what this is,
this to be a massive,
massive attack and they're getting ready to get a brief and here we go.
Back to the book,
the regimental Colonel Stute in the center of the officers and went over the
orders in detail.
Battalion commanders took down notes and their little books.
Then General Barton arrived.
The colonel called attention and everybody stood rigid until the general gave
them carry on and enlisted man ran to the mass truck and got a folding stool for
the general to sit on.
He sat listening intently while the colonel wound up his instructions,
the general stepped into the center of the circle.
He stood at a slouch on one foot with the other leg,
far out like a brace.
He looked all around him as he talked.
He didn't talk long.
He said,
this is one of the finest regiments in the American army.
He was the last regimen out of France in the last war.
It was the first regimen into France.
In this war.
It is spearheaded every one of the divisions,
attacks and Normandy.
It will spearhead this one for many years.
This was my regiment and I feel very close to you and very proud.
The generals lined face was a study in emotion,
sincerity and deep sentiment weren't every contour and they show him from his
eyes.
General Barton was a man of deep affections,
the tragedy of war,
both personal and impersonal hurt him.
At the end his voice almost broke and I for one had a lump in my throat.
He ended.
That's all.
God bless you and good luck.
Okay.
And with that they begin this massive operation.
The first planes of the mass on slot came over a little before 10:00 AM they
were the fighters and dive bombers.
The main road running crosswise in front of us was their bottom line.
They were to bomb only on the far side of that road.
Our infantry had been pulled back a few hundred yards from the near side of the
road.
Everyone in the area had been given the strictest orders to be in foxholes for
high level bombers can and do quite excusable Lee make mistakes.
So did you understand that right there.
So there's a very clear road and they say,
listen,
the bombers are going to be bombing the other side of that road,
but we're gonna back further away from the road just in case something goes
wrong just in case bombs get dropped early.
Okay.
Obviously this indicates,
I'm pointing that out for a reason because this is gets horrible.
Our front lines were marked long strips
of colored cloth laid on the ground with colored smoke to guide our airmen
during the mass bommers bomming dive bombers hit it just right.
We stood and watched them barrels nearly straight down out of the sky.
They were bombing about a half a mile ahead of where we stood.
They came in groups diving in every direction,
perfectly timed one after another.
Everywhere we looked,
separate groups of plane,
we're on,
planes were on their way down or on their way back up or slanting over for a
dive or circling,
circling,
circling over our heads.
And waiting for their turn.
So I want you to picture what this is like.
Picture what this is like and you don't,
don't picture that you're watching it eat a movie cause that's,
I understand that it's easy to picture it.
Okay.
I want you to put your mind in this situation.
Can you imagine what that looks like?
These,
you're the plane that the sky is basically filling with planes and they're
making these incredibly aggressive attacks.
And this piece which I'm about to read,
a big chalk,
this is one of the most magnificent descriptions
of war I have read.
Okay,
here we go.
The air was full of sharp and distinct sounds of cracking bombs and the heavy
rips of the plains machine guns and the splintering screams of diving wings.
It was all fast and furious,
yet distinct.
And then on new sound,
gradually droned into our ears,
a deep sound and all encompassing with no notes in it.
Just a gigantic faraway surge of doom like sound.
It was the heavies.
And so now he's talking about the heavy bombers that are going to bring the
thunder and there's so many of them.
And they're so loud,
it just drones out every other sound until just this massive far away surge of a
doom like sound.
It was the heavies.
They came from directly behind us.
At first,
they were the mirus dots in the sky.
We could see the clots of them against the far heavens too tiny to count
individually may came on with a terrible slowness.
They came in flights of 12 three flights to a group and in groups stretched out
across the sky.
They came in families of about 70 planes each,
maybe those gigantic waves.
We're two miles apart.
Maybe they were 10 miles,
I don't know,
but I do know they came in constant procession and I thought it would never end.
What the Germans must have fought is beyond comprehension.
Okay?
The flight across the sky was slow and studied.
I've never known a storm or a machine or any resolve of man that had about it.
The aura of such a ghastly relentlessness.
I had the feeling that even had God appeared besieging Lee before them in the
sky with palms out stretched to persuade them back.
They would not have had the power within them to turn from their irresistible
course.
Yeah.
This is just,
that's such an incredible description of,
of good,
this impending doom.
I stood with a little group of men ranging from kernels to privates back to the
stone farmhouse.
Slit trenches were all around the edges of the farm yard and a dug out with a
tin roof was nearby,
but we were so fascinated by the spectacle overhead that it never occurred to us
that we might need the foxholes.
The first huge flight pass directly overhead and others followed.
We spread our feet and lean far back trying to look straight up until our steel
helmets fell off.
We'd cop our fingers around her eyes like Fieldglass's for a clearer view
and then the bombs came be began like the crackle of popcorn and almost
instantly swelled into a monstrous fury of noise that seems surely to destroy
all the world ahead of us.
From then on for an hour and a half that had in it the agonies of centuries.
The bombs came down,
a wall of smoke and dust directed by them,
grew high in the sky.
It filtered along the ground back through our orchards.
It's sifted around us and into our noses.
The bright day groups slowly dark from it.
By now,
everything was an indescribable cold turn of sounds.
Individual noises did not exist.
The thundering of the motors in the sky and the roar of bombs ahead filled all
the space for noise on the earth.
Our own heavy artillery was crashing all around us,
yet we could hardly hear it.
The Germans began to shoot heavy high at GAC,
great puffs of of it by the score speckled the sky until it was hard to
distinguish smoke puffs from planes and then someone shouted,
one of the planes was smoking.
Yes,
we can all see it.
A faint line of black smoke stretch straight for a mile behind one of them and
as we watched there were gigantic sweep of flame over the plane from nose to
tail.
It disappeared in flame and it's slanted slowly down and banked around the sky
and great wide curves this way,
and that is rhythmically and gracelessly gracefully is in a slow motion waltz.
Then suddenly it seemed to change his mind and swept up word steeper and steeper
and ever slower until finally it seemed poised,
motionless on its own black pillar of smoke.
And then just as slowly as it had turned over and dived for the earth of golden
spearhead on the straight black shaft of its own creation and disappeared behind
the tree tops.
But before it was down,
there were more cries of there's another one smoking and there's a third one
now.
Shoots came out of some of the planes out of some came,
no shoots at all.
One of the white silk caught on the tail of a plane.
Men with binoculars could see him fighting to get loose until flames swept over
him.
And then a tiny black dot fell through space all alone.
Yeah.
And all that time the great flat ceiling of the sky was roofed by other planes
that didn't go down plowing their way forward as if there were no turmoil in the
world.
Nothing deviated them by the slightest.
They stocked on slowly and with a dreadful Paul of sound as though they were
seeing only something at a great distance and nothing existed between God.
How we admired those men up there and sickened for the ones who fell
incredible.
It is possible to become so enthralled by some of the spectacles of war that man
is momentarily captivated away from his own danger.
That's what happened to our little groups of group of soldiers as we stood
watching that mighty bombing,
but that benign state didn't last long as we watched their crept into our
consciousness,
a realization that the wind droves of exploding bombs were easing back towards
us flight by flight instead of gradually forward as the plan called for.
Then we were horrified by the suspicion that those machines high in the sky and
completely detached from us.
We're aiming their bombs at the smoke line on the ground and a gentle breeze was
drifting.
The smoke line back over us
and indescribable kind of panic came over us.
We stood tensed and muscle and frozen and intellect watching each flight
approach and Passover feeling trapped and completely helpless,
and then all of an instant,
the universe became filled with gigantic rattling of as it of huge ripe seeds in
a mammoth dry gourd.
I doubt that any of us had ever heard that sound before,
but instinct told us what it was.
It was bombs by the hundred hurdling down through the air above us.
Many times I'd heard bombs whistle or swish or Russell,
but never before had I heard bombs rattle.
I still don't know what the explanation of it,
but it was an awful sound.
We dived some got into a dug out.
Others made foxholes and ditches and some got behind the garden wall,
although which side would be behind was anybody's guess.
Yeah,
I was too late for the dug out.
The nearest place was a wagon shed,
which formed on one end of the stone house.
The rattle was right down upon us.
I remember hitting the ground flat all spread out like the cartoons of people
flattened by steam rollers and it's swarming like an eel to get under one of the
heavy wagon we wagons in the shed and officer whom I didn't know was wriggling
beside me.
We stopped at the same time simultaneously feeling it was hopeless to move
further.
The bombs were already crashing around us.
We lay with our heads slightly up like two snakes staring at each other.
I know it was in both our minds and in our eyes asking each other what to do.
Neither of us knew we said nothing.
We just lay sprawled gaping at each other and a few title appeal our faces about
a foot apart until it was over.
There is no description of the sound and fury of those bombs except to say it
was chaos and a waiting for darkness.
The feeling of the blast was sensational.
The air struck us in hundreds of continuing flutters.
Our ears drummed and rang.
We could feel quick little waves of concussion on our chest and in her eyes.
At last.
The sound,
the sound died down and we looked at each other in disbelief.
Gradually we left the foxholes and sprawling places and came out to see what the
sky had in store for us as far as we could see.
Other waves were approaching from behind.
When a wave would pass a little to the side of us,
we were grateful for most of them flew directly overhead time and time again.
The rattle came down over us.
Bomb struck in the orchard to our laugh.
They struck into the orchards ahead of us.
They struck as far as a mile behind us.
Okay.
Everything about us was shaken,
but our group came through on hurt.
I can't record what any of us actually felt or thought during those horrible
climaxes.
I believe a person's feelings at such time.
Our kaleidoscopic an indefinable,
he just waits.
That's all with an inhuman tenseness of muscle and nerves.
An hour or so later I began to get sore all over and by mid afternoon my back
and shoulders eight does.
Though I'd been beaten with a club.
It was simply the result of muscles tensing themselves too tight for too long
against anticipated shock.
Okay.
When we came out of our sprawling and stood up again to watch,
we knew that the error had been caught and checked.
The bombs were falling again where they were intended a mile or so ahead,
even at a mile away,
a thousand bombs hitting within a few seconds can shake the earth and shattered
the air.
There was still a dread in our hearts,
but it gradually eased as the Tomo and destruction moved slightly forward.
Okay.
It seems incredible to me that any German could have come out of that
bombardment with his sanity when it was over.
Even I was grateful in a chassis and way that I had never experienced before for
just being alive.
I fought and attack by our troops was impossible.
Then for it is an unnerving thing to be bombed by your own planes.
During the bad part or colonel I had known a long time was walking up and down
behind the farmhouse,
snapping his fingers and saying over and over again to himself,
God dammit,
God dammit.
As he passed me once,
he stopped and stared and said,
God dammit,
and I said,
there can't be any attack now,
can there?
And he said No.
And began walking against snapping his fingers and tossing his arms as though he
were throwing rocks at the ground.
The leading company of our battalion was to spearhead the attack.
40 minutes after the heavy bombing ceased,
the company had been hit directly by our bombs.
There are casualties including casualties in shock.
We're heavy men went to pieces and had to be sent back.
The company shit was shattered and shaken,
yet company be attacked and on time to the minute they attacked and within the
hour sent back word that they advanced 800 yards through German territory and
we're still going around our farm yard.
Men with stars on their shoulders almost wept when the word came over the
portable radio.
The American soldier can be majestic when he needs to be.
I'm sure that back in England that other men bomber crews wept.
And maybe they did really in the awful knowledge that they had killed our own
American troops.
But the chaos and bitterness there in the orchards and between the hedge roads
that afternoon,
soon passed after the bidding,
bitterness came the sober remembrance that the air force was the strong right
arm in front of us.
Not only at the beginning but CSUS,
Leslie in everlastingly,
every moment of the faintest daylight.
The air force was up there banging away ahead of us.
Anybody made mistakes,
the enemy made them just the same as we did.
The smoke and confusion of battle bewildered us on the ground as well in the
air.
And in this case the percentage of error was really very small compared to the
colossal storm of bombs that fell upon the enemy.
The air force was wonderful throughout the invasion and the men on the ground
appreciated it.
Yeah.
So obviously we talk about blue on blue a lot here.
I think that's about as an extreme example as I've ever heard of.
Hmm.
And,
uh,
you know,
the blue on blue thing is such a nightmare because it's your own people,
it's your own people and it's a lack of communication and it's the fog of war
pain.
You can't do anything you can't shoot back.
While you can do is sit there and wait and it's amazing.
One of those company that was scheduled to attack is so shaken up that they
can't go forward.
But then the other company just go,
we got this step aside.
Yeah.
Now the attack starts pushing forward
and
we get a little description of one of the commanders.
The commander of the regimen was one of my favorites.
He was a regular army colonel and he was overseas in the last war two his
division commander said the only trouble with him was that he was,
that he got to bold and if you weren't careful,
he was liable to get clipped some fine day when tired and dirty,
he could have played a movie gangster,
but either way,
his eyes always twinkled.
He had a faculty for direct thought that was outstanding.
The colonel went from one battalion to another during the battle.
During battle from early light until darkness.
He wore a new new type field jacket that fitted him like a sack and he carried a
long stick that Teddy Roosevelt had given to him.
He kept constantly prodding his commanders to push hard not to let up and keep
driving and driving.
He was impatient with his commanders who lost the main point of the war by
getting involved in the,
the main point,
of course,
being to kill Germans.
His philosophy of war was expressed in the simple formula of shoot the son of
bitches.
Okay?
Once I was at a battalion command post,
when we got word that 60 Germans were coming down the road and a counter attack,
everybody got excited.
They called the kernel on a field fold,
gave him on the field phone,
gave him details and asked him what to do.
He had the solution to nuts.
Nutshell in a nutshell.
He said,
shoot this sons of bitches and hung up.
Okay,
got to keep things simple and you got to keep your,
your tasks very focused.
You know what's all this complication?
We're here to kill Germans,
so kill them sons of bitches.
Yeah,
we'll get to a younger soldier that he goes through a description of Clayton's
weirdest.
This guy named Clayton.
Clayton's weirdest experience.
Be Funny if it weren't so filled with Patheos.
He was returning with a patrol one moonlit night when the enemy opened up on
them.
Tommy leaped right through a hedge and spotting a foxhole plunged into it.
To his amazement and fright.
There was a German in that foxhole sitting pretty holding a machine pistol in
his hands.
Clayton shot him three times in the chest before you could say scat,
the German hardly moved and then Tommy realized the man had been killed earlier.
He had been shooting a corpse.
All his experiences seem to have had no effect on his mile on this mild soldier
from Indiana,
except perhaps to make him even quieter than before.
The worst experience of all is just the accumulated blur and the hurting
vagueness of being too long in the lines,
the everlasting alertness,
the noise and fear,
the cell by cell exhaustion,
the finning of surrounding ranks as day follows nameless day and the constant
marching to Aternity of one's own small quota of chances for survival.
Those are the things that hurt and destroy and soldiers like Tommy Clayton went
back to them because they were good soldiers and they had a duty they could not
define
mental stress.
Now
they continue to push through,
they take Paris and it's really incredible to to hear what that was like.
Then you should definitely buy this book
and read it and here's how he closes it out.
The final chapter is being written in the latter part of August,
1944 is being written under an apple tree in a lovely green orchard on the
interior of France.
It could well be that the European war will be over and done by the time you
read this book or it might not,
but the end is inevitable and it cannot be put off for long.
The German is beaten and he knows it.
It will seem odd when at some given hour the shooting stops and everything
suddenly changes again,
it will be odd to drive down and unknown road without that little knot of fear
in your stomach.
Odd not to listen with animal like alertness for the meaning of every distance.
Sound
odd not to have your spirit odd to have your spirit released from the perpetual
weight that is compounded of fear and death and dirt and noise and anguish.
The end of war will be a gigantic relief,
but it cannot be a matter of hilarity.
For most of us.
Somehow it would seem sack religious to sing and dance.
When the great day comes,
there are so many who can never sing and dance again.
Many,
many thousands of Americans have come to join the ones who have already slept in
France for a quarter of a century.
For some of us,
the war has already gone on too long.
Our feelings have been rung and drain.
They cringe from the effort of coming alive again.
Even the approach of the end seems to have brought little inner elation.
It is only brought a tire does sense of relief.
I do not pretend that my own feeling is the spirit of our armies.
If it were,
we probably would not have the power to win.
Most men are stronger.
Our soldiers still can hate or glorify or be glad with true emotion.
For them,
death has a pain then victory,
a sweet scent,
but for me,
war has become a Fiat black depression without highlights a revulsion of the
mind and an exhaustion of the spirit.
The war in France has been especially vicious because it was one of the,
it was one of the enemies.
Last stance.
We have one big kind of because of many things.
We have one partly because the enemy was weakened from our other battles,
the Warren Francis,
our grand finale,
but the victory here is the result of all other victories that went before.
It is a result of Russia and the Western Desert and the bombings and the
blocking of the sea.
It is a result of Tunisia and Sicily and Italy.
We must never forget or belittle those campaigns.
We have one because we have had magnificent top leadership at home and in our
allies and with ourselves overseas.
Surely America made it's too perfect choices in general.
Eisenhower in general,
Bradley,
they are great men to me doubly great because they are direct and kind.
We won because we are audacious.
One could not help but be moved by the colossus of our invasion.
It was a bold and mighty thing.
One of the epics of all history in the emergency of war.
Our nation's powers are unbelievable.
The strength we have spread around the world is appalling.
Even to those who make up the individual cells of that strength.
I am sure that in the past two years I've heard soldiers say a thousand times if
only we could have created all this energy for something good.
But we rise above our normal powers only in times of destruction
we have won this war because our men are brave and because of many other things,
because of Russia and England and the passage of time and the gifts of nature,
orals materials,
we did not win it because destiny created us better than all other peoples.
I hope that in victory we are more grateful than we are proud.
I hope we can rejoice in victory,
but humbly
the dead men would not want us to gloat.
The end of one war is a great federal broken from around our lives,
but there is still another to be broken.
The Pacific war may yet belong and bloody nobody can foresee,
but it would be disastrous to approach it with easy hopes.
Our next few months at home will be torn between the new spiritual freedom of
half piece and the old grinding blur of half war.
It will be a confusing period for us.
Thousands of men will be returning to you soon.
They have been gone a time
and they've seen and done things and felt things you cannot know.
They will be changed.
They will have to learn how to adjust themselves to piece.
Last night we had a violent electrical storm around our countryside.
The storm was half over before we realize that the flashes and the crashing
around us,
we're not alter artillery but plain old fashioned thunder and lightening.
It will be odd to hear only thunder again.
You must remember that such little thing says that are in our souls and will
take time
and all of us together.
We'll have to learn how to reassemble our broken world into a pattern so firm
and so fair that another great war can not soon be possible to tell the simple
truth.
Most of us over in France don't pretend to know the right answer.
Submersion war does not necessarily qualify a man to be the master of peace.
All we can do is fumble and try once more,
try out of the memory of our anguish
and be as tolerant with each other as we can.
And this book
was dedicated by Ernie Pyle,
and I'm going to read the dedication now
in solemn salute to those thousands of our comrades.
Great brave men that they were for whom there will be no homecoming
ever.
And
Ernie Pyle
did get to experience homecoming.
Unfortunately,
it was not joyous
and it was not long.
He he battled with depression and emotional turmoil
over his experiences in Warren.
You could hear him talking about those.
And also his wife who had some kind of mental issues and she'd actually been
hospitalized.
And so he was distressed and depressed about that.
And on top of that,
the war was not over for him.
And he mentioned there in the end that there's only half piece because there was
still a war in the Pacific.
And he knew that.
And in personal letters and in conversations that he had with his friends,
he explained a personal
foreboding,
a sense that he would not live through the war,
but when he was asked by the Department of the Navy to join the battle against
imperial Japan and the Pacific,
he reluctantly maybe fearfully,
but due to flee.
Agreed to go.
Yeah.
And it was there
in the Pacific on a tiny island called e Shima just off the coast of Okinawa
that Ernie Pyle was shot and killed
by a single sniper bullet.
Okay.
And members of the 77th infantry division who'd been there with for the
operation quickly marked where he was killed with a sign that read
at this spot,
the 77th infantry division.
Lost a buddy
Ernie pile on 18 April,
1945.
So Mr Pile.
Okay.
Thank you for your service and your sacrifice.
And to
the journalists that are out there now in this day,
especially the war journalists who take risks to record and report history.
Thank you for what you do.
Okay.
Again,
the book is called brave men by Ernie Pyle and it will give you some real
insight
into the nature of war
echo.
The world is a crazy place.
Yeah.
And
it's amazing that you can live the life that we live
and some people go through lives their life without ever even
even just brushing against this madness.
And uh,
I'll say this for the thousandth time.
I believe that it is important
to delve into these things so that you learn
not just about leadership but about life.
Okay.
And how precious and glorious
life is.
Damned life has
ups and downs.
It has good and bad.
Good has darkness and light in everybody's life.
Makes those transitions
and
having darkness in the world or in your life does not exclude
the light.
In fact,
I think it makes that light just a little bit brighter.
And so when we,
we don't have to stay here in the darkness,
we can go.
We've paid our respects and we will continue to pay our respects
as we go forward.
And with that,
I guess it's a good time to answer some questions from
the inner webs,
from the inner webs.
Sure.
And actually before we get into questions from the inner webs speaking it inner
webs,
there's kind of some ways that you can utilize the other wet,
the interwebs for other things.
One of them is,
and by the way,
this,
for those of you that don't know
now,
echo is going to say some stuff about the inner webs and about supporting the
podcast.
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to,
I'm going like,
I'm going to be hit a switch and you'll a little decompression with drinks him.
I'm gonna drink some white tea over here with a pomegranate and I'm going to get
a little adjustment,
a little mindset change,
get into the zone for answering some questions.
Sure.
So there's,
there's actually a dual purpose for echos,
discussion of how to support the podcast.
Yes.
You shows you how to support the podcast,
which is much appreciated.
Also,
I can decompress for a minute from being bombed by my own planes,
from being stressed,
from being back in the war zone,
World War Two style.
How he describes it.
I mean,
you can,
you know,
uh,
writers in general or are just really good at explaining stuff.
I mean,
yeah,
pretty much.
All right.
And you can see the difference in the way that men,
this one in particular really to,
to me anyway,
really,
really delivered with the,
with the descriptions and stuff.
And it was like,
yeah,
there's so many one liners in there,
but I'm listening.
W when I was reading it,
I have certain ways of,
um,
I have certain ways of notating kind of what I'm going to read and,
and that,
you know,
some of that stuff's just circled and somewhat since then,
but,
but occasionally if something to me,
if I,
if it hits me,
I put one single red line underneath each individual word,
eh,
that I'm going to read.
And I normally I might do that like once or twice a book,
but there's a couple paragraphs where I had done it multiple times because those
lines are just powerful.
Like the one that I just opened the book back up to room,
can't put it down,
but you know,
when he's like,
um,
and then a new sound gradually droned into our ears,
a sound deep and all encompassing with no notes in it.
Just a gigantic faraway surge of doom like sound.
And this is the part that I underlined.
It was the heavies and you know,
this,
the power of that,
just knowing that these are the heavy bombers,
which,
you know,
it's no big deal to us now because we have giant machines.
But a heavy bomber back then was like a,
it was just this ultimate modern machine that had been created that nothing
could destroy what these things,
nothing was close to it.
And not only who,
we created one of these insane power machines,
we'd created hundreds and hundreds and actually we created thousands of them and
they were all a mast and coming to destroy this little section.
It was the heavies God.
So yeah,
it's a,
it's a book that definitely draws you in.
His writing that he,
that was the fee,
the fact that he writes a very straight forward,
very,
very plain and direct English is I think one of the things that makes it so
powerful.
I love how he can pick up where he compares.
Like,
and a lot of writers do this and when you can do it good,
it's really powerful.
Where like for example,
the uh,
he talked about the one plane that I think he got hit or it was crashing and you
compare it to be,
he said he was a spear of the light lit spear with a smoke trail.
I was like,
Dang,
you can see exactly what that looks like.
And it's weird too because although you can go watch this,
I mean they have film footage of this stuff,
but that,
that takes you there visually.
But I think the reading and listening does,
it takes you there mentally.
He takes you there in your head,
which is more,
which is more powerful than,
and this happens to me all the time when I'm,
when I'm reading it,
I'm getting better.
When we started this podcast,
I could tell like,
oh,
that's powerful.
Like,
Oh yeah,
that's going to be,
that's a really powerful statement.
And then sometimes I would read it and it'll be 12 more times more powerful
where I'd be like,
Whoa,
my God,
I'd be getting just power.
Because when you read it aloud and now I'm a little bit more aware that hey,
you're going to have to read this borough,
you better keep,
you better get your head in the game because it's going to be powerful.
Yeah.
So that's something I've become more aware of as we've done this more and more.
And as I read all these books and gone through them and underlined the stuff and
thought about the way it's going to sound and thought about what it means to say
it was the heavies.
Awesome.
So while I tell it to decompress over here,
Yup.
Go.
Well,
speaking to inner webs and awesome by the way.
Um,
let's talk about supplements it.
So we do a lot of time at this time on it,
right?
Best supplements.
We all know that even though we are already know that that is a big deal because
of the nature of just supplement companies in general.
So rest assured on it.
Best one,
that's it.
On its supplements,
you can get 10% off because of the Jocko link,
which is [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko 10% off.
Boom,
supplement your wallet a little bit.
Sublimate your,
your body and into your mind and your mind off of Brady Alpha brain for sure,
but notably,
Kay,
I'm going to admit some.
I didn't take Krill oil when I went till recently.
So Mira.
Okay.
I in the,
in the spirit of extreme ownership,
apparently I w I was not clear enough to you have you know about the fact that I
wanted it.
Oh,
from when you had sent me a text,
like a bra you got near that grill.
I wasn't just wondering that because
I don't want it anyway.
I'll admit I didn't take that offer.
Marinetec take Jocko,
bring me Krill oil now.
You know,
I think I said that a few times.
Okay,
so I take the Krill oil and I'm not,
I'm not this guy who's like has all these nagging joint pains when I go work out
because really,
that's really when I think,
okay,
do I have joint pain?
No,
no,
no.
I work out good hard or rule Jujitsu.
They do all this stuff.
I don't have joint pain,
but here's the thing.
I do have joint pain when I wake up in the morning.
And the thing is,
like I said,
when you're like,
when I think of when someone says,
do you have joint pain?
I'm thinking when I work out,
that's it.
I don't think like,
you know,
other times unless they're,
they're asking specifically.
So like my daughter,
she's three and a half now.
She's kind of like a bigger three and a half,
two and she comes,
runs up,
wakes me up a lot of times and it's like,
Hey Karen,
me downstairs.
So when I sit up,
she jumps on my back.
She weighs 40 pounds.
I'm not saying I'm,
you know,
the power lift or nothing,
but 40 pounds is not 40 pounds,
I don't think even has anywhere.
Yeah,
no 40
she's 40 pounds.
She jumps onto the back.
I'm like,
oh,
I got to focus,
got to focus on like my,
yeah,
just because of the stiffness,
not necessarily pain,
but just like stiff.
You know how like if you just didn't warm up at all,
you can't just,
it's like that feeling.
And then recently my,
my ankle got jacked up one day and I have like,
I think this torn ligament.
So you kind of watch out your feedback.
Yeah.
You know,
but it had already been jack by the way,
so it got fully locked and then it like inflamed it.
So I got to walk downstairs with this girl on my back with my stiffness and I'm
like,
Oh hey,
no problem.
I do it almost every day.
No problem.
But let's face it,
those are all signs of gentleman challenge.
Yeah.
But I take the Krill oil,
not the first day,
not even the second day,
but it was maybe a few days later she jumps on my back.
I'm still working out hard by the way.
So it's not like,
Ooh,
you recovered.
She jumps on my back.
I'm like,
Dang,
I feel solid.
I can go like when I stand up I'm like boom.
Popping up.
Noticeably reduced still there.
My ankle is still there right now.
It's still,
but bro,
this was like,
I would say maybe four or five days and this is what I know.
I was like,
Dang,
this is,
this is good oils.
Real.
Yeah.
And there's been a bunch of bunch of people on Twitter who have come back and
said,
hey,
I started taking krill oil.
And then a week later they're like,
man,
my shoulder's good to go.
You know?
It really works.
So it does really work.
It really does.
Yeah.
And then like I said,
that mean,
and here my wife's dad was like telling her lung,
this is years ago saying no Krill oil,
no one,
not fish official who's good.
Krill oil is that.
And I'm like Krill,
I look up Krill.
It's the trim.
Like,
oh sweet,
it's joint pain,
it's all this stuff or whatever.
And like I said,
even back then,
right now,
same thing when I work,
I don't have joint pain.
Maybe if I have a strain of stuff,
but that's my joint pain general,
you know?
So I'm like,
all right,
good for you.
Fucking knock yourself out with a crude oil when I need it.
And then I'm going to come on,
maybe I'll ask you about some stuff.
So you know,
I see it and it's cool.
Good,
but this is the first time I really like,
I get,
I got you.
The krill us now.
You get that,
get that.
So when I run out,
go ahead.
Give me another Krill oil.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's clear.
Yeah.
Cool.
All right.
Let me know.
We'll sell you sell back to the book.
What else were your bars in this?
This is what we,
I think were birds are made out of the buffalo meat.
They are artists.
They are,
we never said that.
Oh well my boss does that even matter,
you know,
because because you're eating buffalo,
which must be stronger.
Well,
yeah,
but um,
nonetheless,
to me that makes it even more awesome.
Not because,
I mean not for any specific reason other than maybe novelty,
but it's still pretty dope in my opinion.
Um,
so still tastes really good.
That's for meal replacement.
Someone asked me on Twitter,
Hey,
do you,
you know,
what meal replacement or protein shakes or whatever,
would you recommend if any?
None.
Yeah.
Well that's what I said too,
is someone said the same thing to me,
meal replacement.
I said,
why would you replace a state?
But in the event,
not really,
the answer to that is gross or disgusting or horrible.
Maybe you'd want to replace them or you don't have to look,
I'm driving a truck.
I'm driving a,
I dunno,
a airplane or something for a long time.
I want you to driving my airplane and all due respect.
Yeah,
probably right.
But,
but okay,
there you go.
Worrier bar.
That's the SRA
filler.
Eat Two of them.
That's a big filler.
Eat three big,
they're not messing around and they're good.
That's the thing.
Like,
remember back in the day that you know the,
the bars
back then,
even right now,
you eat one of those like,
oh,
all right,
I see where you're going.
Whether you're trying to make it like a candy bar where you're trying to,
it's not like that at all.
This is good.
Anyway,
don't worry about our salad.
Um,
another week.
It's,
uh,
support the podcasts in the event of you being in the mood to support the
podcast is next time you go shopping@amazon.com,
click through one of our links.
It's like a passive way,
actively,
aggressively efficient way to support and super easy.
It doesn't cost you anything.
You Click through,
you do your shopping,
boom.
It's like we get like a referral thing.
Well,
what I like about that is because I don't want to ask people,
like a lot of people,
they want to donate money.
I don't want you to donate money to us.
If you want to give us money,
that's awesome.
But I'd rather you buy a tee shirt if you can afford it.
But if,
let's say you can't afford anything because you're broke,
that's okay.
When you order something from Amazon,
this is just free money that you give to us.
So it's all good.
Yeah.
In a way,
it's almost like a collective,
hey,
we all shop at Amazon,
we're in this thing together,
you know,
kind of thing.
I don't know.
It's,
it's an Amazon planing buster with spare the change,
right?
They can spare it a little something for the Jocko podcast.
You're actively making Amazon give us money.
How's that for getting after it?
But then,
but,
but there,
you know,
so it's like this weird like circle almost,
they,
you know,
they buy from Amazon.
We're like,
hey,
go to Amazon but go through us.
And Amazon is like,
hey,
thanks for buying.
Thanks for sending them.
We're supporting Amazon,
whether it be books or whatever,
duct tape,
all this stuff.
Cause we're making people want to buy stuff from Amazon I.
E books.
Sure.
Yeah.
The less people are gonna need to buy a,
a white dude from [inaudible] from Amazon too,
which is coming so good.
You know,
it's so good.
It came out so good.
I'm pumped.
Yeah.
That's going to be solving that is solid currently.
That's solid.
But yeah,
the Amazon it anyway,
again,
it's support that way.
Um,
like I always say a big part of that or a big issue,
but it's a thing in there is remembering to do it.
If you want to do this,
the remembering to do it.
So we do have what's called the trooper tool.
All it is.
If you go,
you download it and it's basically you click on it,
Samsung trooper trooper tool,
chrome extension,
click on it.
Except that it's on your thing.
It automatically does it for you from here on out.
Dope.
It's like a little official thing to it.
So solid.
Um,
and
we were trying to update,
I've been talking to him,
I'm trying to update it for Canada,
UK so they can have the tool for them as well.
That's cool because yeah,
we're working on that one but they,
Yay.
That's good.
Trooper tool.
You don't have to remember it anymore.
You remember at one time that's all shop at Amazon still support aggressive Lee
efficiently
and the of course support by subscribing to the podcast on iTunes and youtube
channel.
Grab to the Youtube Channel.
Yeah,
that's legit.
And of course the Jocko store.
Oh I think we're,
I'm not,
I think I know that we're trying,
we are trying our best to provide multidimensional items.
Like even in a simple tee shirt is multiple,
multiple dimensions to it.
You know,
it's not just,
hey,
that's a cool saying.
The saying is important and extends way beyond what you'd expect on the surface.
That goes for all the shirts.
So including the rash cards,
including the rash guys.
Okay,
so new stuff,
new stuff.
The rash guards,
the rash guards are good as far as the fit of course.
And that man did good.
And what I what?
What's cool about,
I mean,
here's the reality,
when you,
when you put on a uniform,
Yup.
When you put on a uniform,
you change your mentality a little bit.
This is factually,
Yup.
Factually.
And so when people are like,
aw man,
I was wearing the discipline equals t d d discipline colloquium teacher today I
got my PR on clean and jerk.
And I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
You,
you put on your uniform and there's a mental like state of mind that makes it a
little adjustment in the brain.
You know what's real funny about that exact notion?
When I,
when we first got the first shirt to this lineage was freedom.
I put it on the gray one and I get,
I know that that thing that's,
it's,
it's a psychological thing.
Yeah.
By the way,
one of the most powerful things in your whole life.
Psychological.
Anyway,
so I put it on and I was like,
yeah,
I'm going to take a picture of me in the new shirt kind of thing and I put it on
at night and I was going to work on anyway and man I put it on.
I was like,
yeah,
I felt that exactly on the shirt that I made,
you know.
Anyway,
yeah,
it's so true.
And the rash guard,
I'm not going to go into the story but I put it on the rash guard yesterday.
You're working.
It worked out very well.
I did very well.
So there's some sort of a subliminal power that you can gain.
Yes.
So true.
And when else thinking rashes,
it's false advertising.
If you were this rash,
this rash guard,
your Jiu Jitsu would improve 19% how false that off.
And I went in to the whole rash guard situation like,
Oh yeah,
we need rash guards because people were saying,
hey,
we need like this rash guards and there were Jujitsu,
there was a demand sick.
But here's the thing,
like rash guards,
like the short sleep all Brad,
this is like if you go like biking and stuff,
that's really what it's for.
It's like biking,
uh,
like crossfit.
Anything where you're like,
that's really what rash guards are for.
I mean Jujitsu now cause there's just no,
but we used to back in the day,
we used to just where we were,
if people were wearing rash guards,
there was no such thing as Jews who were not rash guard.
Right.
There was only actual Rashford restaurants.
And you know what it is for bodyboarding is what it is.
Cause you get a rash
for all means of water sports.
Yeah.
And uh,
my,
my little brother,
he's a diver,
he died spear fishing.
He's dope too.
He thought he got this.
Anyway,
he's on quiet.
So,
um,
same thing.
You go diving waters,
but it's like,
that's what this is for,
including,
but not limited to Jujitsu to just as a complete bonus on the tail end of that.
But if you wear this for now,
these are specifically designed for to do too
there for everything and just multiperson.
Yeah,
it might multipurpose.
Yup.
And straight up.
If you wear for Jujitsu,
you're going to do better.
I'm making that claim.
Ashtray.
A lot of it.
I love it.
Nonetheless.
He,
I've got rolled with you while you're wearing it.
Yeah.
Good luck.
Good luck with that one.
We will go to the gym after this recording.
Also new that's out is patches for Jujitsu for anything.
They're just patches do you can sell on their iron on,
but you sold so I'm on,
so I'm on.
Yeah.
Um,
patches.
Discipline equals freedom.
There is a Jujitsu specific patch.
It says Jujitsu sued,
you know,
discipline.
Anyway,
go on the chocolate store.com you can see him all and women's shirts.
Women's shirts are new.
Back to the patches real quick.
So I got a recommendation for the velcro.
One is,
I don't even know why I didn't like it.
Didn't dawn on me.
You don't wear a hat?
Oh yeah.
You don't wear hats.
Yeah,
but still I had all the time.
There's always a space for a patch on there,
so I'm going to put it on everything.
There you go.
Anyway.
What about the women's shirts?
Women's shirts.
Okay.
Yes.
Thank you Debbie.
And um,
you know all you guys,
every one of the female troopers.
I got it.
Yeah.
At least
they're on you employee.
They bring very good input and I think him and I respect their tenacity.
You feel threatened?
I felt that we were all in this together,
you know.
Um,
but yeah.
Thank you.
So yes,
they are coming here.
Here's the thing.
They're not tee shirts.
Their tank tops.
Cool.
Do we want t shirts?
I don't know.
If we do then we're going to be few shirts as well.
Good.
Ask ass females.
Female troopers.
Maybe we'll do a pink.
We will not.
Maybe we will though.
That's the thing.
We will not,
either way they are in the,
literally in the works submitted is that Lisa's like pink,
pink,
pink man.
Ooh,
not happen.
Yes.
Vetoed.
I didn't really feel like doing the pink either.
So guess what?
I did the paint.
Actually I didn't do the pink,
but it's in the works still.
Nonetheless.
They're on the way on the way if you don't want this is decentralized command
folks.
I'm not micromanage and echo and he's got the creative brain so you know,
let them run with it.
And humility because just cause it's not your specific opinion doesn't mean
it's,
you know,
but
there is a standard of,
so hopefully you maintain it.
I guess I'd just be,
you know,
I'll try and give you the proper guidance.
Right.
Well there you can talk to make that happen Jocko.
store.com.
That's it.
That's where they all shop.
And thanks everyone for shopping and supporting.
It's awesome.
And should we go to the questions?
Oh wait,
one more thing.
Just a little technical thing.
Okay.
Outside of the u s if you're outside of the US,
Canada or anywhere else,
I do the US.
Um,
I put a little thing on there cause just w as far as just the shipping process,
technical thing.
Um,
for customs,
they want you,
your phone number to create this shipping label.
I need a phone number.
I'm not going to give the phone number out.
I'm not gonna call no one texts.
Nobody.
But they just need it for the customers.
So I've tried to put a thing on there,
but hey look,
you're shopping.
You just want to check out and be done with it.
I understand.
But if,
if possible,
try to Chyna,
remember that one?
Otherwise you've got to email them.
It's no problem.
I'll email for for good.
Yeah.
Hey,
look,
ship along way.
Exactly right.
In this Cleo,
in Holland,
there's so many people.
This is what's really cool is getting feedback from people all over,
all over the world.
That's crazy,
right?
Yup.
That's kind of crazy,
right?
Yes.
He's all over the world troopers getting after it.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
People come in from
Sweden.
Yup.
Well they came in,
came to the gym.
Didn't roll though,
but we hung out.
We talk about physics,
properties of physics to fit good physicist listening,
physicist that.
Guess what?
He likes to listen to the podcast.
We don't talk about physics.
Okay.
Yeah.
Indirectly you did.
But yeah,
if you can try to remember the phone number.
So it just,
it seems the step and boom,
it's on.
It's on its way to you quicker.
There it is.
I don't mind emailing.
No.
In fact,
I get a lot of cool little conversation like the Australia,
you guys,
for some reason I love those guys.
They'll be like,
hey,
and they'll say the Australian stuff.
I was in Australia,
you know,
a couple of years ago or whatever,
and Medscape,
Jason,
he's a black belt under Hickson and he has it.
Anyway,
I was with him doing some stuff and he teach me all the Australian stuff that,
and some I didn't know,
like too easy,
for example,
too easy.
It's like,
yeah,
I got this.
Yeah.
Like all the like,
yeah,
it's just this real,
it's kind of ambiguous,
but it,
you know,
I love that phrase anyway.
Nonetheless.
You know,
you get into fun conversations with people when you email them for,
for the simple stuff,
for the shirt order,
whatever.
Good,
good.
How long have we been,
how long have,
how long did that go?
Oh yeah,
roughly two hours roughly.
All right.
Well,
I actually got a pretty good stack of questions.
Um,
I'm thinking that
for today and we wrap it
and hold off on Q and a until the next one and we'll just do all Q and a on the
next one.
I don't do be quite frank with you.
It's Kinda tough to even follow up with this book.
So,
so with that,
thanks everybody out there for,
for listening,
for supporting the podcast.
Thanks for taking the time to learn with me,
to remember with us
the depth
of the world,
the depth of the darkness
and
the sacrifices
that have been made
for us.
And
remember that.
Remember that,
remember these men and what they were really truly afraid of,
not afraid of physical agony,
not afraid of death itself,
but they feared losing their future.
They feared losing their future.
Okay.
So we here
sitting here
today,
we have a future.
We have that opportunity.
So make sure you take every
possible advantage of the opportunity that you have
and that you have in the future.
And you know how to do that.
Yeah,
you do that by getting out there.
They're getting after it.
And so until next time,
this is echo and Jocko.
Okay.
Out.